lightwood simon robert labour party
13166
this is the moment they've been waiting
for labour finally winning back one of
their heartland seats wakefield in west
yorkshire their leader who has long
struggled to convince people he's a
winner still facing criticism even at
the center of a resounding victory what
happened here in wakefield was people
exercising their judgment on this
conservative government and voting no
confidence but some of those voters are
saying that they are defecting to you as
a protest this time it's a lack of
enthusiasm for boris johnson not
enthusiasm on the back of that result
here that swing i'm afraid that argument
just doesn't carry people came across
the labour party because the labour
party was talking to them and for them
swing labour keen to claim this win but
was it anger with the conservatives that
changed the game
these wakefield golfers say conservative
support here has run its course i think
what they've been offering i think um
it was a time for a change and
definitely a time for a change because
everybody's falling out with the
conservatives
because of all the bad press and the uh
the parties and
boris is a clown
it's the lies under the sea in it really
that's what everybody on everybody's
lips i think there'll be a change yeah
yeah i do but um because people are fed
up fed up yeah yeah
a big result for labour a 12.5 swing to
them and although by elections are very
different from general elections if you
did extrapolate that result across the
country it would see labor backing
government the conservative vote
collapsing all very encouraging for kia
stammer but is he the person to make
that happen or could the conservatives
come back
today's news has convinced many of the
area's conservative mps that holding on
to their seats means getting rid of
boris johnson but after he won a
no-confidence vote earlier this month
he's safe for another year and those who
are prepared to speak publicly are
putting on a brave front i've spoken to
some of your colleagues one of them said
to me
if i was a redwall mp i'd be looking for
a new job i don't think it's fair to say
yeah he's
lost everybody's support and he's
completely finished that's not my local
experience as
some people are understandably furious
others are minded to give him another
chance your colleagues will have your
eyes on him yeah i mean that's
yeah that's what politics is like isn't
it you know so
obviously we all
yeah
we all want to keep our job and we're
all watching these issues intently so
what's the big picture after years when
the outlook was nothing but gloomy and
they watched the political landscape
shift against them there is now a
slightly clearer way forward for labour
and maybe even more change on the
horizon liz bates sky news in wakefield